DOCTORS.
>>AK VIDEOTORUST EDURERURIGHT
NOW, AND THEN WE'LL ALL DISSS W
PROFESSIONALS,
YEDNTER.I THIN I
RLFORINCREDIBLE JOB
BEEN DOING.
HERE, WNG
WELL.
ETLLTH
H BECAUSEE
STILL HAV T M GREATAIN.
WE'VE DONE A AWF GD THAT.
BUT WAVETEPS TO OHAT.
AND I'LL BE BACK 'L SOON.IWARD
THE WAY WE'VE BEE THE
WE'VE BE'VE BEEN I SOMETHING TH
HAPPENED AND IS
WORLD. THEM
JUN
I'M A WLDE GOINGO BEATHISS OR WT
OFRE CT SOON THAT ARE
F  KNOWHE
THEYEOPLE CRITI I T WE HAVEHIAP
THAT LOOK MIRAC , WANT TOL YOU
I' SRTEEL
YOU DRIOD OEW ST.
WE WHAHO TO BEOL
FOPORT I'VEEN IT'S ON TELEVISIO.
OF
BEEN BYMERICA  B AARTISAN
F AMERICAN PEOPL
IT'S A TO AATE
AND I WON'T FORGET IT.ROSE THA
I AL THE LEADERS FOR THEIR
CONDOLCE --T GNG THROUGH. AS TO.
I WAS OPTION.
STAY IN THE WHITE HOYOSEON'T   .
ST UPSTAIRSNDJO IEE PE DLE AND A
I O
THAMERICA, TS
UNITED STATES,
THISTH
COUNTRY IOCUPSTAIRS SAY  WTEWE U
THERE'S NEVER BNATLE DONE
SO,T' I
I'M DOING WELL. TNKBOSTSK TO S
LOVE THAHE
COUNTRY.
AND WOTHNGL. RINGERY
AS YOU'V PROBABLY SHE'S
SLIGHTLY Y THAN  AREFORE
THE DISEASE.
WE KHE PEOPLE, AND
MELANIAING IT
ST ID
ANESERY  MAKES COUNT
HAPPY.
BUT I'M ALSO AND IK 'RAVE A VEE.
EOI.
SO I JUST TO THANKERYBODYUTBODY
OUTPOURING OF LEAS
I
TH RIGHT
PRESIDENT POSTED TAAGO, 4
I SAID.
LET'S GET REACTIO NOTA IS WITHS
WHAT DU Y?
>> WELL, I KNOW, H
EDOR MINUTES THEREVIOUSL EXTEMPU
GIVING SOME, DETAIL
FEELINGYEL
STHAT HE SEEMS TIMPROVING.
THERE'S NOT A LOTF- HEALT LOOKS.
I DON'T KNOW THATCAMORE IOT,WO.E
ODAY
WI,LHAT HAPPENED, AND
THEN HEAIDNG BEAT CORONAV.E ALS
WHAT HEAL T
HECD THEMIRACL ABOUT THAT, SAN
ERICS.Y
EXPENT HASN'T EVEN BED UND --ALD
ANTIDIHAT -SODS B THE NFEREN ON
YOU ESRE
TRYING TO CREATE WHEU OTHER WAY
GET THE  AL ANTIBODY THERAPY ITA
EVENUG LOT OF
DATA T'S LOTF
USTHE' THEUT BACK THE
INFECTION,ENOUGH ANTIBODY, EASI
FOR ITHAPPEN.
MAYBE IT'S A OF THE
YOU VERECHSERIZED
MEDICATION,ITW FAST THE V
RESO, PUT T.
WE D'TNOW
IMYB H GOTTEBETTER ON HIS OWN.T.
ENAV S
IT TELL. DOESR
ARED TOCRIBED
YESTERDAY.
>>ET GET TA OUR
CHIEF WTO THIS.
SAID
HEUTORL MILT TEAR
NT
WHAT WAS YOURNO?
>> ITOU AS THOUGH THE
PRESIDENT AY VIDEO THAT HE WA G
OUNIT'S I ITWAIONO GR
COULDN'T STA
CONFINEDDE A ROOM INSIDE E WHITE
PHYSICIAN, AND TS
BY THE AND "NEW YORK TIM MARK MS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S HEAH.
I  AOONENT IRIME WHY THET AND T
NATION'SAL RIGHTERE ARE PEOPLE E
WHSIORLD Y THE
LAST 24  CFROM T MY S
INSIDE T AND
INMPCAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE  CE
IR WHITE H
FICIAL EARLIERID,
YOU TREYESTERDA TNOW, BIT
CORONAVIRUS CLD TAKE A TURN E W.
SO ILLFGHNESENERHITE E,MPLE GO
OVER TO WALTER
WOLF,T DIA
WHAT
YESTERDAY WHO WER
PAINT A RTU OF THH AND
RO OFFERED BY DCONLEY, THE WHITN
TALK ATHE WAY THE
PROGSS T
ILLNESS, THECHANGENDKLY A
SO, IT'S A THING T
AR REED.UT
FACT THE IS
ALSO IS IY  ONAL OR THATENUP ON
FRIDAY.PICALLY WHEN YOU'RELAN O
SUPPLEMENTAL OXYGEN.
THOSE TWO TREATMENT G IN ACCORN
EN PROBLEM?
>> WELL,EA FIRST A FIVE-DAY C
GIV  I MENTNEATN Y BY BLOCKIN
ABILITY TO  AS
I THINK WITH RHE
THINGS.
U'HE
ENOU TIM HEARD FROM THAT
NT RAMPED FOR A WLE WASAM
. EARLIER DY  IT FWERE HORE B
THEY SAIDF BLOOD DROPSWYOU N SUE
THAT'SROM. HEL KNOW HE WAS  NI'E